battlefield 3 oh my god I wouldn't say
we liked us but we have a history with
it because the first time we've ever
went to e3 we end up ended up scoring
about 25 cases of green oz so it's kind
of a novelty for us to see it at this
point get my nose
god I can't wait for Skyrim
who it Activision do we know that gave
us these passes Robert is this your
doing I think this could be great
excellent
easily oh my god
that's why I don't have a connect oh
wait we can play trackmania the Speed
Racer was a game to the media we won
ready one got down here you guys hit the
nos to lose we hit up the nos pretty
hard and white in a wait wait you know
when stamp because I got the hot
reflexes that no one else got
say well he thinks a box office the best
degree I've ever been through actually
really crazy proportions
I like this dress jetan babe set up
abandoned train wreck
this way more girls into c3 and the past
two weeks I've been doomed
why combined why why
I'm time here Sam you think v3 so far
sucks bay doors are closed it
playstation always has going classy
boots
good
but our doing to this animals
Dora go
go amigo
Oh
so hot
walk but now
rap music
my version b3 that the vast majority of
game designers take the same game and
reskin it over and over
however couple cool ones out there I
think EA and uh yeah yeah it's kind of
got it this year they have mass spec 3
battlefield 3 so it's kind of over you
know it doesn't have it
Square the square Enix is still
infatuated with boys with pink hair all
right Nico's review home for the pretty
lights leave after you see the games and
the pretty lady and the three nos